So the last type of combine approach that we will discuss and that has seen an
increase in both research and in practice is mindfulness training and
psychotherapy. Specifically, mindfulness based cognitive therapy or MBCT is an
approach that combines elements of both cognitive behavioral therapy with
mindfulness meditation to help people with depression for instance, to learn to
recognize and restructure negative thought patterns. This therapy uses both
mindfulness meditation and cognitive therapy to restructure one's thoughts. So
mindfulness meditation develops skills for approaching thoughts in a
non-judgmental way, and enhances people's ability to realize that they are
neither bound nor defined by their thoughts, feelings, and sensations, and to
detect symptoms before they become a problem. So this approach has been used
successfully in preventing the relapse in depression, and in addition there's
some research to show that mindfulness based meditation therapy has been used
successfully in treating positive and negative symptoms of schizophrenia. The
idea here is that this therapy can be used by teaching people with
schizophrenia to learn to live more easily with their symptoms, and to not be
defined or controlled by them. One new approach focuses on changing the
relationship that people have with the voices in their heads rather than trying
to make those voices go away. Some early studies have shown that this technique
results in less distress and improved functioning after training in mindfulness
meditation. So if you're interested in trying meditaion, take a look in the
instructor's note box. We've provided you with a link to more information about
mindfulness meditation.